hello
so sorry
after the few hours i started to speak
french anyway
even during the english show
okay h5 now he's back back to business
boom if you play h5
a ways man said if you play
h5 it means you play
h4 this wise man was called
magnus carlsen boom
go for it
so e3 queen c4 he only needs the door
but okay it's
a bit uh you know he's not going to
to play a quince gambit and try to make
a dough
my d5 looks very good here to me
to my eyes
knight d5 how do you protect here a3 ah
preventing knight before okay this is
another way to do it
knight f6 okay
missile before bishop b2 i guess
we need to okay it looks like not enough
to me
but who cares we've seen worse
okay now is we'll probably at some point
come back here play d6
knight g4 maybe testing
yeah exactly don't try this at home
that's a very good uh point
crazy six okay i'm not a fan of queen e6
but i don't know
oxy one makes a lot of sense open file
you can go knight f4 b5 try to collect
on c7
also d6 you see this knight is a bit
weird 97 is playing so he's playing with
fire
and he knows it he's not
he's not the knife type who knows
okay it's for one you can play a bit
with fire
knight a4 c6 okay but in
as goes saying in bad positions
it's difficult to find good moves
so c6 okay and castle now
this makes some sense yeah he wants f4
maybe
takes an f4 ali
takes on f4 yeah that looks very very
good to me
opening up f4 immediately okay he wants
to take
after probably bishop c7 knight c5 is
uh really painful and magnus is going
for e4
okay and now
what should we do
maybe f5 knight f5 bishop s3
something like that
queenie one okay you want some
queen h4 ah 95 bishop h3 i guess
just pin
and it looks suddenly very very good for
i mean not suddenly
it looks winning for for white simply
i mean winning might be a bit strong
actually
he's fighting again this is just passive
yeah
some end game but there is some
compensation there is a pawn for the
exchange
i don't know hi fish 45
and
welcome welcome to the show
magnus carson show white is better now
he has to win he's in must-win situation
he told zagat
for the next three games situation is
not exactly
great for him but
he's still alive and he has a better
position here i would
i would say i'm not 100 sure
this is exciting yeah the score is not
exciting but the games are really
exciting
um so
what is it going to do h4 go for it
eduardo
that'd be six of course i'd say for 38
seconds
i'm not optimistic for eduardo here
okay it's hard to be optimistic for
eduardo anyway g3 or g1
you have to do that what else what else
can you do with rado
who just replayed ah okay shade oh it's
so good
and now c7 h6 you have g6
poo too strong
too strong too fast two minutes against
20 seconds
he's too good what can we say
hook g2 yeah but how do you improve your
position now bishop h3 any move
yeah i think i don't see a plan for for
eduardo here
you just wait magnus
or maybe we'll reboot his knight to f5
that's also an option
i don't know
145 against 15 seconds
i'll catch six
and okay one time to find some some play
okay anyway it's the same
thing is six okay makes sense takes a
knight b5 i guess
g6 okay or catch five will come
yeah okay seven but i don't think it
protects
uh anything take on h5 yeah and slowly
magnus is taking over
surprise big surprise
magnus carson taking over again in that
game
push all is protected
who wouldn't take black here
h3 yeah that's just uh
hard to imagine something happening to
black here
94 attacking d2 touching b6
the bars you see the evaluation bars
that's why it's not good to look
i mean i would really advise you not to
look at it
because look i mean like it's showing
it's equal but
it's not equal at all i mean like i mean
it's equal
but uh it's just so easy to
so so much easier to play for black
so much more comfortable i mean there
you go g3 or f3 i mean okay
it's just white survives but
okay that's just a nightmare
and it doesn't need to win so
that's too many that's
too many problems for men
okay magnus thinking king is six
check he's exchanging hooks
at least he's offering a trade uh
oops did he blender opponent king d7 or
cafe
i'm such a jinx actually
i mean i just said that magnus would
have
what can happen to him 10 seconds later
is losing a pawn
this is just insane
somebody now the twitch this french says
a
debate to know if i'm french or not
i'll let you guess um
okay sorry sorry i missed many moves and
eduardo is
making it wow that's a surprise actually
now he's completely winning threatening
to take our streets i think bishop e5
this is just insane
this is just insane take on s3 i sound
very british
that's the first time i hear that but
okay thank you
rg7 bishop f5 still still fighting
magnus
if he saves that one that would be
just incredible again
okay now you can ah okay okay seven is a
good move
takes takes takes now what can you do
you cannot do much
okay five check and now moving the
bishop is uh
oh [ __ ] four
still fighting this is just insane
will he make it
we see he wants to resign but no
he's fighting he's a fighter it's great
eduardo might win that i mean come on
exchange and pawn up
i think it's going to win but
yeah that's okay now he wants to
to liquidate into one who can ingest d4
or c5
this is hard to believe something will
happen
here but again
so many things happen now here is